your end game is legendary it baffles
experts
so uh can you linger on that then try to
explain what the heck is going on there
like if you look at game six of the
previous world championship
uh the longest game ever
played in chess
it was uh
i think
uh his queen versus your rook knight in
two pawns yeah there's so many options
there it's such an interesting little
little dance and it's kind of not
obvious that it wouldn't be a draw so
how do you escape the it not being a
draw and you win that match
no i knew um that for most of the time
it was a theoretical draw since um
chess with seven or less pieces on the
board is solved
so you can like people who watching
online they can just check it they can
check and
they can check a so-called table base
and they it just gonna spit out win for
white win for black or draw so
and and also i i knew that i knew that
didn't know that
position specifically but i knew that it
had to be a draw so for me it was
about
staying alert
first of all
trying to look for
the best way to put my pieces
but but
yeah those end games are a bit
they're a bit unusual they don't happen
too often so what i'm usually
good at is i'm using my my strengths
that i also use in
in middle games is that i evaluate well
and i calculate short variations
quite uh even for the end game short
variations match yes it does matter in
some simpler end games yeah but also
like
there are
these theoretical end games with very
few pieces like rook knights
and two pawns versus queens but a lot of
end games are simply defined by the
queens being exchanged
and there are a lot of other pieces left
and then it's usually not brute force
it's usually
more of
understanding and evaluation and then
then i can use my my strengths um very
well
why are you so damn good at the end game
isn't there a lot of moves from
when the end game starts to when the end
game finishes and you have a few pieces
you have to figure out it's like a
sequence of little games that happens
right like little pattern like how how
does it being able to evaluate a single
position lead you to
evaluate a long sequence of positions
that eventually lead to a checkmate well
i think
if you evaluate well at the start you
know what plans to go for and then
usually the play from there is
is often pretty simple
let's say you understand
how
to
arrange your pieces and
often also how to arrange your pawns
early in the end game
then
that makes
all all the
all the difference and
after that is like what we call
technique
of very often uh that it's
technique basically just
means that um the moves are simple and
uh
these are moves that you know
a lot of players could
could make not only
not only the very strongest ones these
are moves that are kind of understood
and unknown so with the evaluation
you're just constantly improving a
little bit and that just leads to
suffocating the position and then
eventually to the wind as long as you're
doing the evaluation well
one step at a time to some extent also
yeah as i said like if you evaluate it
better and thus
accumulated some
some small advantages then you can you
can often make your
your your life pretty easy uh towards
the end of the end game so you said in
uh 2019 sort of the second phase
of why you're so damn good
you uh you did a lot of opening
preparation
what's the goal
for you
of uh the opening game of chess is it to
throw the opponent off from any prepared
lines
is there something you could put into
words about why you're so damn good at
the openings
again these things have changed
a lot over time uh back in kasparov's
days for instance
um he
very often got
huge advantages from the opening as
as white can you explain why
there were
several reasons for for that
first of all he he worked harder he was
more creative and finding ideas he was
able to look places others
didn't
uh also he had a very strong team of
people who had
specific strengths in
in openings that he could use
so they would come up with ideas and he
would he would integrate those ideas
into yeah and he would also very often
come up with them them himself also
at the start
he had
some of the first computer engines to to
work
for him to
to find his ideas to look deeper to
verify his ideas he was better at using
them
than a lot of others
now i feel like the
playing field is a lot more
level there are
both computer engines neural networks
and hybrid engines available to
practically
anybody so it's it's much harder to
find ideas
now that um
that actually like give you an advantage
with what the
the white pieces i mean people don't
expect to find those ideas anymore now
it's all about
finding ideas that
are missed by the uh
engines either they're missed entirely
or they're missed at low depth
and using them to
you know gain some advantage in the
sense that you have more more knowledge
and
you know it's also
good to know that usually
these are not complete bluffs these are
like semi bluffs so that you know that
even if your opponent makes all the
right moves you can still
make a draw
and also at the start of 2019
neural networks had just started to be a
thing in in chess and uh i'm not
entirely sure but there were at least
some players
in even in the top events you who you
could see did not use them or did not
use them in the right way and then you
could gain
a huge advantage because a lot of
positions they were
being evaluated differently by the
neural networks than traditional chess
engines
because they simply think about chess in
a very very
um different way so
short answer is these days it's all
about
surprising your your opponent and
taking it into position where you have
more more knowledge so is there some
sense in which it's okay to make
suboptimal quote-unquote moves no you
have to
i mean you you have to
because the best moves have been
analyzed to to death mostly so that's a
kind of when you say sami bluff that's a
kind of sacrifice
you're you're sacrificing the optimal
move the optimal position
so that you can take the opponent i mean
that's a game theoretics yes you take
the opponent into something they didn't
prepare well yeah uh but you could also
look at it another way
that
regardless like if you turn on
whatever engine you turn on like if you
try to analyze either from
the starting position or the starting
position of some popular opening
like if you um analyze long enough it's
always going to end up in a draw
so in in that sense you may not be going
for like the objective
the tries that are
objectively the most difficult to draw
against
but you know you are trying to look at
least at the less obvious um paths okay
how much do you use engines do you use
leela
stockfish
in your preparations my team does
personally i try not to use them too
much
on on my own
because i know that when i play you can
obviously cannot have help from from
engines and
often i feel like often having
imperfect
or knowledge about a position
or some engine knowledge can be a lot
worse than
than having no knowledge
so i try to look at engines as little as
possible so yeah so your team uses them
for research for a generation of ideas
yeah but you are
uh relying primarily on your human
resources
yeah for sure you can evaluate well
you don't leave yeah i can evaluate as a
human i can know what they find
unpleasant and
and and so on and
it's
very often the case
for me to some extent but
a lot for for others that you arrive in
a position
and your opponent plays a move that you
didn't expect and
you know if you didn't expect it you
know that it's probably not a great move
since it hasn't been expected by by the
engine but
if it's not
if it's not obvious why it's not a good
move
it's usually very very hard to figure it
out
and so then
looking at the engines doesn't
necessarily help because at that point
like you're facing a human you have to
sort of
think as a human
you